y en este vídeo hablaremos sobre
fecundación y desarrollo temprano en los
seres humanos aquí tenemos una imagen
real de esta fecundación que está a
punto de ocurrir tenemos un
espermatozoide y esta es una de todas
las células del esperma que proviene de
un ser humano masculino mientras que
aquí tenemos un óvulo que está siendo
fecundado y que se encuentra en el
interior de un cuerpo humano femenino
entonces la fecundación ocurre cuando un
espermatozoide y un óvulo se une esta es
la concepción de lo que tiene el
potencial para convertirse en un
organismo real en este caso de
convertirse en un ser humano primero
vamos a conocer la escala que tenemos
aquí para poder tener una mejor idea de
qué tan pequeñas son estas células vamos
a suponer que esto corresponde
aproximadamente a un cincuenta hbo de
milímetro así que esto ocurre a una
escala sumamente pequeña ahora es
importante recordar que esto ocurre al
inicio
nuestras vidas y para que pueda ocurrir
se necesitan cientos de miles de
espermatozoides que están en competencia
para lograr llegar al óvulo así que
debemos sentirnos orgullosos de nosotros
mismos porque ganamos una gran carrera
piénsenlo un poco la mitad de ti que
proviene de tu padre ganó una carrera de
entre los cientos de millones de otros
espermatozoides que estaban compitiendo
para llevar el adn de tu padre y
fusionarlo con el adn de tu madre que se
encontraba en el óvulo pero cómo es que
se empaca el adn bueno el adn se empaca
en forma de cromosomas y los cromosomas
son simplemente tiras de adn en el caso
de los seres humanos la mayoría de las
células de nuestro cuerpo contienen 46
cromosomas que en realidad son 23 pares
de cromosomas porque por cada parte
tenemos un cromosoma de nuestra madre y
uno de nuestro padre
a las células sexuales se les conoce
como gametos lo escribiré estos son los
gametos el espermatozoide es el gameto
que proviene de nuestro padre y el óvulo
es el gameto que proviene de nuestra
madre entonces los gametos tienen la
mitad del número de cromosomas
cada una de estas células tiene 23
cromosomas no 23 pares sino 23
cromosomas así que cuando el
espermatozoide y el óvulo se unen es
decir una vez que el óvulo es fecundado
nuevamente se tienen 46 cromosomas
organizados en 23 pares de cromosomas
pero como se ven las células cuando
ocurre la fecundación bueno aquí tenemos
la fotografía de un cigoto es un óvulo
fecundado que tiene todos los 46
cromosomas y podemos ver que en el
núcleo hay dos células que todavía no se
han fusionado completamente a éstas se
les conoce como pro núcleos pero en
algún momento se fusionarán y si
pensamos en nuestro primer día
como una célula podemos decir que ese
fue el día en el que las configuraciones
genéticas que obtuvimos de nuestro padre
y de nuestra madre se unieron para
formar una nueva configuración genética
que en algún momento nos dio toda la
información necesaria para construirnos
tan pronto como esto ocurre empieza a
una división celular mediante el proceso
de mitosis este cigoto se divide en dos
y después en cuatro y así van ocurriendo
una o dos divisiones celulares por día y
después de dos o tres días ya hay ocho
células y después dieciséis células a
esas dieciséis células se les conoce
como modular y con el tiempo todo eso se
sigue dividiendo hasta que después de
cinco a nueve días se logra algo como
esto no se ve muy bien pero aquí hay de
200 a 300 células pero el interior está
hueco y a esto se le conoce como
blastocisto
blastocisto pero observen que esto se
encuentra aproximadamente en la misma
escala es ligeramente más grande que el
lóbulo que originalmente fue fertilizado
y esto continuará dividiéndose una y
otra vez y para poder apreciar todas las
etapas de las que estamos hablando
cuando hablamos de la fecundidad nos
referimos a esta parte todas las
imágenes que les he mostrado
corresponden a esta fase y después de
tres cuatro cinco seis siete días quizá
en la primera semana llegamos al estado
del blastocisto así que nos encontramos
en esta etapa ahora algo que
probablemente les intriga es porque
empiezo en la segunda semana bueno lo
que pasa es que aquí es en donde se da
la edad gestacional que es algo que los
científicos y doctores usan para medir
qué tanto se ha desarrollado el embrión
y en particular la edad gestacional se
mide desde el primer día del último
ciclo menstrual de la madre que puede
ocurrir dos semanas antes del momento de
concepción
estoy mostrando aquí pero bueno eso es
algo técnico pero es muy interesante
explicar el por qué tenemos este desfase
de aproximadamente dos semanas entonces
una vez que entramos en esta fase ya se
considera que existe un embrión y casi
al final de esta etapa podemos decir que
ya existe un ser humano en potencia que
se ve como esto aquí ya pasaron
aproximadamente siete semanas después de
la concepción y podemos ver que esto
sigue siendo muy pequeño porque este
aproximadamente un centímetro de largo
aproximadamente el tamaño de un arándano
pero todavía no se ve propiamente como
un ser humano o al menos un mamífero una
de las cosas más fascinantes sobre la
biología del desarrollo es que si
analizamos el reino animal especialmente
si analizamos aquellas especies muy
relacionadas con los seres humanos
podemos ver que aún en esta etapa los
embriones son muy parecidos pero ya
empezamos a ver algunos rasgos que
reconocemos por ejemplo aquí
en los brazos aquí podemos ver que se
empieza a formar la oreja los ojos la
nariz e incluso aquí podemos ver las
costillas y todo esto ya empieza a
formarse y a verse como un ser humano
pero todavía es muy pequeño y si
analizamos el desarrollo de otros
mamíferos o incluso de otras especies
como el pescado podemos encontrar
embriones muy similares a este en esta
etapa pero una vez que pasamos a la
décima onceava o doceava semana ya se ha
formado el feto entonces aquí tenemos un
embrión que surgió de la fecundación del
óvulo después se convirtió en un cigoto
que después pasa a ser mórula y de
modular pasa hablando sixto después
tenemos el embrión y de embrión pasamos
al feto esta es la imagen de un feto
aquí podemos ver que está conectado a la
placenta la placenta es el sistema de
comunicación con el cuerpo de la madre y
aquí podemos ver que el feto aún sigue
siendo muy pequeño claro
depende del tamaño de su pantalla pero
esto corresponde a aproximadamente 5
centímetros en la vida real así que
tenemos un feto de 5 centímetros y la
frontera que hay entre un embrión y un
feto en realidad no está muy definida
por eso vemos este punto de transición
pero muchas personas consideran que para
la doceava semana ya se ha formado el
feto ahora algo muy interesante es que
aquí podemos ver todo el ciclo hasta
llegar a la semana número 36 de la
semana 36 a la 42 se considera que el
embarazo está por terminar y un bebé
está listo para salir pero aquí también
podemos ver la noción de la viabilidad
que es el tiempo aproximado en el que
hay una oportunidad de que el bebé pueda
nacer y sobrevivir por sí solo eso es
muy interesante por ejemplo aquí podemos
ver que existe aproximadamente un 50 por
ciento de probabilidad de que el bebé
sobreviva a los 6 meses pero
la idea general es que cada uno de
nosotros empezó con una enorme carrera
de cientos de millones de
espermatozoides para lograr ser el que
pudiera fecundar al óvulo de la madre y
después esa única célula es decir ese
cigoto que contiene la información
genética tanto de la madre como del
padre después de que el óvulo ha sido
fecundado empieza a replicarse una y
otra vez hasta que años después se
convierte en un organismo complejo capaz
de hacer vídeos y reflexionar sobre cómo
se desarrolló nos vemos en otro vídeo